moi je suis depuis toujours convaincu
qu' une grande part de la solution c'est
l'éducation
ok c'est le gros bon sens
l'environnement faire attention à nos
trop faire attention notre énergie c'est
le gros bon sens mais si on n'est pas au
courant de ces choses là est possible
qu'on pose un compose pas les bons
gestes de montrer à nos enfants à bien
se comporter à respecter les ressources
à consommer de façon intelligente mais
je pense que ces gars en d'avenir ça ça
vaut faire durer les actions qu'on va
prendre aujourd'hui dans les écoles
c'est effectivement j'ai deux jeunes
enfants puis il passe beaucoup pensent
probablement plus de temps dans leur
école qu à la maison
alors si l'école montre pas l'exemple si
effectivement la cafétéria on a des
bouteilles d'eau parce qu'on veut pas
s'équiper ou on veut pas avoir une
laveuse industriel pour la vie des
gobelets si si on fait pas attention aux
lumières si on laisse les portes les
fenêtres ouvertes
est ce que vraiment on transmet un bon
message aux enfants je pense je pense
pas donc oui effectivement faudrait que
toutes les écoles concret ou qu'on
rénove aujourd'hui soit le plus
écologique possible mon lieu l'aspect il
ya l'aspect financier qui n'entre en
ligne de compte on sait que c'est pas
facile
la question la question qui tue c'est ce
qu'ont ce qu'on investit dans
l'infrastructure ont investi dans les
gens je pense qu'il faut il faut faire
tout ça à la fois
mais l'idée d'avoir un cours d'avoir au
moins des notions qu'ils soient
transmises à nos enfants au niveau du
développement durable de de l'approché
écologique
je crois que ça c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait être mise en place assez
facilement
on ne plaint d'experts au québec on a
plein de personnes qui sont capables de
transmettre le message
puis on a plein d'enfants qui sont
avides d'apprendre ces messages là qui
vont les transporter chez eux et qu'ils
vont dire à leurs parents papanou à
l'école on fait du compost
les choeurs de pommes on les jette
jamais dans la poubelle on les met dans
le composteur parce qu'avec ça on peut
faire de l'engrais puis avec ça on peut
faire pousser les plantes alors
transporté ces notions l'a apprise à
l'école à la maison mais ça va faire en
sorte que peut-être des parents d'une
autre génération vont être influencés
par leurs enfants puis éventuellement
passer pour le mieux tout le monde
savait dans la même direction
non mais récemment la maison que je
devais mettre moins de pression lorsque
je voudrais le robinet pour les poissons
donc après avoir fermé le robinet quand
j'étais jeune pour se brosser les dents
maintenant on est un ami
une coche plus loin si on veut
d'atténuer un peu encore davantage notre
eau donc évidemment les messages
circulent dans différents milieux
demande saas en garderie mais on
comprend que plus vieux ils y apprennent
autre chose madame lessard vous voulez
réagir
oui j'ai ouï je mens à réagir par
rapport à ça pour plusieurs et comme
trois points que j'aimerais passer un
des premiers points c'est l'éducation
l'environnement complètement par contre
il ya un élément intéressant que j'ai
entendu récemment qui m'a vraiment me
changer un peu ma façon de voir les
choses
oui l'éducation il faut vraiment
insister puis enseigner le développement
durable dès le jeune âge mais par contre
faut pas penser non plus que cela c'est
suffisant parce que le cerveau humain
est malléable jusqu'à plus ou moins 25
ans que ça veut dire c'est qu'on n'est
pas encore notre personnalité
nos valeurs c'est pas encore tous forget
jusqu'à + 25 ans plus ou moins quelques
années et ça j'ai trouvé ça intéressant
parce que je me suis dit ok donc pour je
peux juste miser sur l'éducation des
enfants faut aussi faire perdurer sa
salade doublement des répercussions de
faire sucer si tu fais d'enseignements
sur les enfants les enfants rapporte eu
à leurs parents après donc là le yo
comme une pérennisation qui peut
s'instaurer
mais je pense que c'est aussi c'est
comme faut juste faire attention de
faire perdurer sa parce que sinon je
pense que si on focalise seulement sur
les enfants risquent de manquer quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas compris au niveau
biologique au niveau cognitif